[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
some people have a deep abiding respect
for the constitutional law that created
this country
and some people don't
[ __ ] it started liberalism
mud club can stop it
join mud club for exclusive content
shows and to help put a stop to
homosexual liberalism
[Music]
well a lot of people watch women's
sports yeah when men win them
this fall
six cities
prepare
for not one
but two
rebels were the cause credit where it's
due that leah thomas really swam her
balls off
the rebels with a cause comedy tour
tickets on sale now at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's a delicious sip that's an excited
tip because we have donald trump jr on
the show today oh boy not a moment too
soon because uh i don't know if you know
about this but the stuff that garland
said that we reported on last thursday
and then part about the passport
yeah everything we said was wrong
really yeah because they changed
everything oh
so that's the beauty of doing this show
live with you is you can watch us get
the information as it comes in we do our
best to verify turns out they're wrong
or they just lie well yeah all right so
we have a lot to get to also uh we'll be
talking about you know john wayne is in
trouble with the academy for uh
littlefoot the broad who claims she
assaulted him the academy officially
apologized oh i'm gonna change the
airport again yes
question i'm gonna change it to uh what
do they change it to bob hope i don't
know i think it may still be john wayne
it could be bob hope yeah but he said
something racist and playboy in 1970s
where actually said something
progressive yeah i know no it's racist
i'm kind of amazed that they didn't say
worse things yeah i just feel like we
should just read cagney and it should
just feel like a kkk screed right always
amazing like oh yeah it was a decent guy
you know we're getting better pretty
astonishing my question to you is before
we get to that uh how many of you right
now if you're watching right now are you
aware of the indians that they're sorry
india in america that's what i said back
then so i'll be saying indians today so
hold your offense or please comment i'd
like to see it
there's siege in a south dakota town in
the 1970s i don't know if you're aware
of that we'll talk about that and uh
donald trump junior roles i'll show you
some updates here in the new uh new
studio new digs gerald a is here how are
you i'm well sir how are you okay doing
okay yeah i'm doing okay and he's the
quickest man on his feet quickest wit in
the west i'll be on tour with him here
uh we're both together on tour here uh
in the fall uh phoenix september 16th
arizona federal theater houston
september 17th smart financial center
sugarland we've had to expand uh those
two theaters yes and then charleston
west virginia october 8th we have not
had to expand that yet because no one
lives there
are you sure no one lives there let's
just you'll have to drive in it's dave
landau ahoy how are you sir what's that
shirt oh it's a desert moon oh it's ufos
oh okay in the desert that's where i
find them yep
of course
that's where the
janitor of area 51 also kept his mouth
shut yes yes they really found some
secretive bastards there
uh by the way okay sorry uh dave um we
have some breaking news
[Music]
uh breaking news this is coming in right
now the cdc has just declared a national
pandemic of homosexual men having sex
with dogs
now here's something else
that uh we can get to does that count as
homosexual
well no they were homosexual before oh
bestiality i do this is a choice they
you know they spice it up
just it's a pandemic dave
he barked consent
woof means no and uf means yeah yeah
uh this is something that i just saw i
was watching a show i don't really see
commercials all that often did you ever
think about this i'm going where would i
see a commercial
because on youtube you know i i i have
it all uh i have it to say we have to
have youtube they give us partners a
whole youtube plus whatever it is yeah i
don't watch television so i saw this
because i happen to be watching
something on the history channel it's
one of those free channels that was
given to me and i thought oh this is
this is a joke
have you seen this one yet yeah well
i've seen the history channel or as i
call it the hitler channel yes yeah the
hunting hitler channel also yes special
on mermaids very true
thanks history channel hitler mermaid
also i don't know if you know it's the
learning channel primarily to teach us
about angry midgets and fat people yeah
yep that's it obesity and dwarfs the
more you know
this is a com
wow
quick
so i'm just trying to make up for
something venus
razors uh they released this commercial
i saw it i thought it was a joke it's
not it's an actual commercial for venus
razors
and it's um
i'm not offended to be clear it's just
gross to say the least
you can find tutorials for the masses
for doing brows and curling lashes
but influencers won't mention me
is the word pubic blast for me
[Music]
[Applause]
did they say pubic mound yeah they did
they're being sued by almond joy
i'm more concerned about why your pubes
are on everything you own
self-care would be clean in your fridge
but it's your choice why is your pupil
it was left on there there's a little
fur toilet seat like what are you just
setting pubic hair traps
venus has the tools so you can do you
well do you get rid of it how did you
clog a sink with that
there's enough there for a wig what is
this
[Laughter]
she's shaving jazz palm and terry's back
in the bathroom
i mean i find if you want to like push
this but don't have pubic hair singing
and dancing through your videos well
it's like the venus one where they had
the uh they were trimming the shrubs if
you will
and then it was just shapes of you know
what like uh landing strips or whatever
like it was an actual commercial john
wayne airport yeah that's funny they
changed it yeah it was fine but like
this is just it's curly cues just like
hey
they change it to dorito municipal right
what about us yeah we know we know what
we can do it's everywhere it's in your
comb it's on your toilet seat yeah it's
on your like just can you run a vacuum
like get a swiffer you you made a pubic
chair for your rug yeah you did that's
an odd like here you go get comfortable
my problem isn't with the hair to be
clear it's it's with its uh origin
where it came from and the smells that
typically emanate from said areas it's
not the cleanest part my problem was
with the honestly i i've you've heard me
say this i really it's the
commercialization like i was a fan of
people here before it went mainstream
sure you were yeah really when it when
it all became about money i didn't care
anymore yeah it's the pubic hair
equivalent of american idiots you're
like hmm this is a pubic scene it's not
the same as dookie really they really
they were great in the 70s
and it's just kind of now they're just
self-important yeah
you've given up you're phoning it in
pubic hair
hey by the way uh dave can you give uh
my uh my boot back
that i don't have your boot uh no i
think i gave it to yesterday for the
sketch yep that was not me yeah oh wow
okay sorry i didn't i thought i'd give
it a bit i need to find my boot uh later
by the way it's a live show monday
through thursday 10 am eastern that's
the best thing you can do tune in
because notifications won't work you can
uh
expect this kind of go ahead there
it's kind of riveting content
10 a.m eastern monday through thursday
on rumble or on mug club of course light
of credit.com will do extend it with
donald trump jr like we did with carrie
lake because there's stuff we can't say
on youtube right
freest and fairest selection in
history uh and you can subscribe to the
audio podcast uh if you want to you have
allergies eyes hurt something like that
yeah allergies someone blew a pollen
into my face all right i'm allergic to
pubes yes
not all no no that one just sneezing all
day because your bathroom who pitched
that was it is the person who wanted to
buy the world of coke dead probably so
they say you know what i get it let's
have a cart let's let's do a commercial
that looks like the [ __ ] bay based
kid selling pubic hair hey i feel like
you see her with a lint roller you're
like do you have a cat and she's like no
oh it's not a matter of speaking by the
way you want to see how to do an ad
about pubic hair and how to control it i
see our manscaped ad that we did that's
hilarious that is true and perfect yeah
but we knew that it was inappropriate
but we did it it was it was
tongue-in-cheek they thought this was
art it was hairball and cheek yes
that was that would have been a sketch
three years ago yeah maybe three years
trying to think back to work
i got an idea of dancing i would have
been on snl like that's a little too on
the nose yeah
yeah 20 19 probably yeah that would have
slide we can have dancing needles we can
certainly have i love the background a
pubic hair
yeah
they had to have three
pubic yeah
why do you want to shave so bad if
you're going to wear jeans to a beach
that's right it's so stupid
i want to roll it back yeah
jeans to a beach but a tank top and full
[Laughter]
also do you notice she's alone on the
beach oh yeah yeah why do you think that
is
because they're like oh that's the broad
who shaves her pubes every time she's
out here is her trail of tears
i forget there's a northern wind
soap someone just with their daiquiri
this is the last time i go to sandals
yeah this is terrible
i don't want that bartender again the
one that wears jeans on a beach
a pubic collada
all right
let's get to this donald trump there's a
lot of rain
it's just the ocean there's a turtle
who's moved on from straws
it's a venus razor
with
the carpet
deep
the state of advertising
you know here's the thing i get to be
like what are you shaming i get that you
have it so do we here's the difference
between men and women in our advertising
we don't demand that you find our main
beautiful we get it it's gross we should
take care of it you do it in private
okay
it's not beautiful
and stop wearing jeans at the beach now
yeah it's ridiculous and personally i
don't care if your shrub is nonsense
i've never complained
it's vintage yeah
i
i like records
[Laughter]
why is this record scratching is it well
no it kind of
gets stuck on the mound
that's how it happened
oh that's it we need that sound bite the
pubic hair singing
how crazy would it be if you went back
and you played ozzy's like crazy train
backwards and it's that commercial
newly discovered
mama
pubic hair
[Laughter]
i am
[Laughter]
guys you're supposed to go to a
different house first of all and write
pubic air on the garage when i get to
the balls i'll go back right up to the
shaft
and then someone killed cops that's the
problem yeah that was what it was john
lennon ends poorly oh
guarantee he didn't use a penis no i bet
you'd be yoko's looks gross
[Laughter]
you
[Laughter]
steel wool
strips the paint
you ruined my truck yoko and the beatles
hit the like button if you're okay with
this uh
trust me we're getting into the fbi
stuff but
we said have fun yeah
i like to have a laugh are you having a
laugh now
you can uh comment below
as to have you been confused with the
trump fbi updates uh
i i really do think that
i think the most commonly used tactic of
the left now is to memory and it works
pretty effectively right where we will
come in two days later and go did we get
that wrong i feel like on air we talked
about
did we make it up yeah and we go no no
we didn't hear the references oh oh they
changed the story two hours after the
show so there's a real value bring up
cnn right now just oh my gosh it's john
kasich with the baby bird and an oil
spill haircut okay just so you can
someone clean them off with dawn
i almost went palm olive but we're too
light
two hippies come in sir
little towel
all right they toss a venus at the broad
the producers are gonna be mad because
we're taking too long okay
so
girl rightfully so
uh
you can see that we're doing this live
there's a real value to doing this live
most people pre-tape it or people do
things live they're not really hitting
breaking news because it's a risk right
with youtube they'll label you
misinformation you can get removed if
something gets changed but there's a
real value in making all of our
references publicly available uh because
we check them again and we go when's the
time stamp on that yeah we did run it it
was correct so let me set this up uh for
you and i want you to comment before you
watch this segment as to what your
understanding is of
uh the events that have taken place with
the fbi raid the passports the um of
course giving giving the okay with
garland on the warrant
where do you think it stands now because
you're probably wrong i guarantee you
you'll get at least one out of three
wrong okay so
this is what happened initially right
according to president trump uh he said
the federal agents confiscated uh they
confiscated his passports okay
uh this was what he posted i believe on
truth social he said wow in the raid by
the fbi of mar-a-lago they stole by
three passports what expired lfo
there's still three ones expired i was
up to date with the others
very timely not that one i let it lapse
what are you a spy
there's a bunch of currencies
three passports one expired along with
everything else this is an assault on a
political opponent at a level never seen
before in our country
third world
third world it works i love it
i love it so this brings us to uh well
let's go through this then and now
[Music]
was that system of a down
it might have been i like system
overdoses the toxicity of my passports
and my passports
one's expired
wake up why don't you put a little oh
makeup oh gross
[Laughter]
left the kids in the table that's a bad
pair you're a bad mother okay so then
this is what the media uh
initially report on the passports right
they reported on it as though donald
trump was making wild claims regarding
them taking the passports all of you not
you if you're watching right now but a
lot of people in this country actually
believe that he was fabricating it
here's why former president trump is
saying on his own social media platform
that his passports were among the
documents she's been using index mr
trump not thrilled about it as you can
see here but keep in mind that those
passports were not on the list
on the receipt for property unsealed by
that affidavit last week you can see
what was on that affidavit 11 sets
of classifieds top secret or other
sensitive materials nbc news has not
been able to obviously confirm the claim
that mr trump is making one way or the
other by the way in the background that
beach was brought in jeans
why
who would do that
um so for example a daily mail headline
read doj slaps down trump's claims that
fed stole three of his passports during
mar-a-lago raid so that's what they said
then
here we are now
the justice department their officials
are now saying that the passports
have been returned from nbc news the fbi
acknowledged it had the passports the
same day trump said on his social media
platform that the fbi agents who
conducted the search on august 8th
took them so to be clear
they didn't have them
they gave them back
this entire investigation has been
nothing but inconsistencies and sleight
of hand if you if you didn't understand
before that the media is not in cahoots
with this administration that's why i
said there one in the same you know it
now is that
oh the boot okay thanks
i'll put on later
so there we go didn't have the passports
didn't take it they gave him back i know
and i can't she could she have like
looked any more like suspicious of his
claim right she was like ugh he's
claiming i never had that but the
passports yeah
one set of documents random documents
was on that list right it could have
very easily been in that one set of
random documents that she was talking
about why didn't you just say we'll have
to wait and see if they actually have
his passports or not and they're like oh
yeah we have the passports well i think
it's just good that we have uh people
that are in in investigation finding
three passports and going these look
like classified documents yes exactly
right this is one was the diplomatic
passport by the way then it's personal
then they expired it's like these have
no bearing unless you're trying to keep
somebody from fleeing the jurisdiction
right guys i guess
i found i found a cup
yeah
[Laughter]
well this this just echoes the first
claim that was made donald trump comes
on and says my home was raided then the
media comes out and says no no no a
search warrant was executed it's a
different thing then we're like oh they
kicked everybody out said the lawyer
couldn't be present they were there for
nine hours and they had tons of agents
searching everywhere sounds like a rage
and by the way let me ask you this if
because they're saying a warrant and
this is again a slight a warrant means
there's a very specific reason they go
and there's a process you see the
warranty which they did not provide to
them they saw it from 10 feet away they
didn't allow the lawyers to be present
right and they go in for something
specific
a raid and technically they're kind of
one in the same that's when you just you
know ransacked the house as you've seen
in the movies right they go through the
drawers kind of like the sticky bandits
and what happened
they took the passports it's a raid
yeah that's not that's not a warrant for
classified documents they took his
passports which we now know they did
irrefutably all references available at
autograph.com that's a raid now do we
know for sure if they went through
melania's panty drawers we can't know
i'm willing to bet they did they broke
into a safe let's say they did though
take the passports deliberately isn't
that so you can't flee because you were
raided
well no no that's that wouldn't be how
it would work like you would have to
surrender your passports right another
process that oh there was well they
would also have to prove that he's a
flight risk right exactly so it's a
whole different process i've only been
in a house that got raided because they
had uh illegal pets right
yeah it's really amazing how much a
hedgehog goes for well it really is an
alligator coke crack house it's not
important
details i had hermit crabs it was a
problem when they started making shells
out of venus pubic hair i had two
hamsters and ren ate stimpy
i'm serious that's sweet okay downstairs
is dead now here we go back to
then in the beginning right you had
merrick garland attorney general uh
had no clue about the raid on trump
right that's what the media reported
here you go you have this from newsweek
was it newsweek or time we had donald
trump in a prison outfit in shackles
news newsweek okay all the news that's
fit to illustrate
so um again this is the value of doing
it live because we even reported as much
live on our show thursday again because
every major outlet was reporting it to
be true and i couldn't refute it at the
time because there were no resources
that refuted it at the time but i did my
level best here we go from last thursday
that morning
a.g garland didn't know what was going
on a senior justice department source
called the raid a spectacular backfire
and also said that garland had no prior
knowledge of the date uh or the time of
the specific raid nor was he asked to
approve it ah how does that work ah is
that possible do you see what's
happening here lying eric garland right
now is seeing it hit the fan and going i
am distancing myself chris ray
sacrificial lamb here you go public yep
he is absolutely just this maybe it's
true i doubt it maybe it's true but he's
definitely putting chris right out there
by himself
i would say his ma admonish me but uh i
called it
it's pretty clear this is this is what
we have to navigate here on this channel
just so you know and this is why the the
biggest line item outside of employee
payroll is legal you know that because
youtube if we at that time said i
guarantee you garland knew about it if i
said it as stated as a fact
we could have that removed from
misinformation that could be a hard
strike at the time we couldn't
emphatically state that because we could
not verify it but you see it didn't pass
the sniff test that was about
uh was that maybe around 10 30 eastern
in the morning on thursday yeah okay
which brings us to
now
garland then came out well later that
day to say that he personally approved
the warrant for the raid okay
wow you know that you already know that
but here's the thing i remember this was
thursday when he was giving his little
press conference there yeah i don't
believe he took questions and uh he said
that he would unseal the warrant if
trump agreed yeah everywhere on twitter
was oh merrick garland mike dropped
because now donald trump is screwed this
is 11 11d chess because if donald trump
denies won't allow the warrant to be
unsealed then he looks guilty but if he
does unseal it's going to show that he
was giving away nuclear codes
that's what was happening thursday and
friday well guess what donald trump
called us bluff but he didn't just ask
for the warrant to be unsealed he asked
for more and that brings us to this
political theater so donald trump uh
posted not only will i not oppose the
release of documents i am going a step
further by encouraging the immediate
release of those documents here's the
thing the warrant which was released
tells us nothing
donald trump wanted the affidavit
release the affidavit is the complaint
right it's the reason right the
complaint for the warrant that would
have had to be cleared yeah this is why
we need a warrant all of the details of
what they're going after right the doj
is actively fighting to keep the
affidavit sealed oh
really again why because that affidavit
would prove the justification for the
rate it would prove what they wrote down
was the reasoning for the raid on donald
trump's house so isn't this beautiful
political theater first off they say we
need to make this go away uh garland
didn't know about this and all the media
lackeys go out and say that they say oh
no one's gonna buy this anymore so it
comes out and says i did i did approve
it and i would approve it again and by
the way i'm gonna if donald trump wants
to play this game let's release the
warrant so the public can decide the
warrant just says here's a warrant
donald trump says release the affidavit
to justify the warrant so the media
gives the story the press to this
administration and garland look they're
being transparent
they don't follow up on the fact that
that same administration the doj and
let's be honest one in the same here
they work together say no hold on a
second we don't actually want people to
read the details yeah and they're
they're using cover here and i had them
add this into uh our show today because
it kind of hints at what's going on here
so they're saying oh we can't do it
because it might reveal witnesses
the other part is they're saying methods
and everything else but the other part
is a criminal investigation so this is
from the hill the doj said the
disclosing the affidavit would cause
significant and irreparable damage to
the inve to a ongoing criminal
investigation um so does that mean that
you're currently right now investigating
donald trump is he under a criminal
investigation at this very moment yeah
are you guys going after him because
that's what they've said too it's like
oh they're just getting the documents
back there's no criminal investigation
then other people on the left are saying
oh there should be a criminal of course
is that why you're not going to release
it or you just don't want us to see yet
again another hoax i can guess there you
go that's there you go just asking you
we were leading the witness because you
know what the next thing i'm going to
say here's why affidavits matter anyone
who's worked in law and by the way i
know way more about legal issues than i
should unfortunately having to swat down
the stuff with youtube and twitter and
facebook and working with my half asian
for all of these years and he's
unbelievable shout out to to bill i know
he's working hard uh the reason these
affidavits matter for example just to
give you a concrete example that you can
remember 2020 the doj admitted right and
this was through the affidavit we found
out about the russia collusion hoax the
steele dossier was discovered through an
affidavit and then you were able to do
your own research regarding the dossier
fusion gps the affidavits reveal the
information so this is from 2020 the doj
two of the four court orders along the
fbi to conduct secret national security
surveillance on former trump campaign
aid carter page were not valid because
the government made material
misstatements in obtaining them uh the
fisa warrants they were they were
incredibly important by the way to
pushing the russia collusion hoax
collusion hoax and that was a
justification yeah but this was two
years later yes two years after the
russia collusion hoax has been going on
and on and on and on like a morphine
drip from the media yeah they finally
come out and be like oh well this was
actually illegal to begin with right so
that's why people are pushing for it and
we wouldn't have known if not for the
affidavits no and sorry that's what's
important we don't trust you yeah of
course we don't trust you and you'll
have what jim schuette on cnn saying oh
this is the promise people are
threatening violence against the fbi
look that may or may not be true there
may be some people out there that's not
what we're doing but i absolutely don't
trust the fbi absolutely don't trust the
doj don't trust the cia why would you at
this point when we've had
any kind of information that we were
demanding released to the public guess
what it's been bad
for obama spying on the campaign for
hillary clinton for of course merrick
garland we know it's always been bad
they don't operate in transparency they
operate in the dark we're still waiting
by the way and those numbers released
from governor whitmer the foia request
yeah for the nursing home deaths we
don't have those
so it's a beautiful it's a beautiful
parlor trick that they play oh uh
garland didn't know oh hold on a second
actually he did know and then he comes
and says by the way unseal this and they
say well i'm saying we can't actually
unseal the information that people
really want okay well you know what
let's actually just uh keep that seal
where's all of the 8d 11d chests for
donald trump like there was for merrick
garland on on twitter oh trump called
his bluff trump is backing him into a
corner nowhere the media's not saying
that how about this where's donald trump
on twitter why is he not allowed
yeah he's not allowed to speak you know
publicly
but well he was the president he was the
president i know no but i mean at least
now by the time i know what you mean
and of course not not is no it is
clearly was not voted to be a second
time that would be absurd even though by
the way the washington post i think is
running an article about election
tampering with machines right now and
their concern over
the ability to
i think that article came out either
today or yesterday
thanks where's the evidence though
that's what bothers me like they there's
always this stuff without evidence like
you guys got that uh grab em by the
billy tape pretty fast yeah
you're furiously searching for stuff of
course never find it this is why donald
trump is is doing better in the polls
look americans now inherently know that
they have gone over this guy with a fine
tooth comb they've been doing it since
he ran for office the first time let
alone you know starting up in 2015
and there's nothing okay he can be
bombastic okay he tweets out a little
bit too much sometimes he's a bit of a
bullshitter not a not a fundamental liar
like joe biden or garland but he'll
exaggerate things like third world
you don't fact [ __ ] you don't need to
fact check that wapo we get that that's
that's hyperbole and they're going after
his business dealings right now saying
oh maybe he he had a misstatement on
that do you understand how accountants
prepare this stuff and by the way do you
remember geithner uh the guy that was
the head of the treasury yeah yeah uh in
his confirmation right he was yeah yeah
timothy gunner he was he was actually
informed that he owed i think 10 million
dollars in back to he's like oh oh that
must have been an oversight i guess i'll
pay that yeah this happens to people all
of the time and that's what they're
going after trump see i told you his his
guy is being called up before the uh the
spring and then rudy giuliani we had him
on just the other day now they're giving
him crap and putting him potentially
under indictment in georgia for what he
said yeah i know he's unbelievable
they're going down a list every time and
by the way the list is long you're next
on the list they're going after donald
trump they're going after the business
dealings they're going up to the family
they're going after giuliani they're
going to go after every single person
who at any point actually january 6th
right they're going after people who
didn't even enter in the capital uh
you're on that list next what do you
think they're going to do with over 80
000 new irs employees what do you think
they're going to do you've looked at the
numbers we don't need to go back through
that again you're going to be paying
more in taxes if you're middle class you
know that i know that what do you think
they're going they're trying to send a
message
just like barack obama did it's one and
the same right barack obama with
targeting of his political opponents
with the irs did donald trump do that
because if he did do that again the
media would be running that on a loop
like a morphine drip and we would be
going after him for doing it of course
because you can't do that right
all right it doesn't matter well what is
it that giuliani said
just like he was just saying that the
election was fraudulent and they claimed
that they're in you know there were
discrepancies in georgia yeah so they're
trying to say that are they trying to
argue that he was tampering or they're
trying to argue that that's what i
thought but like yeah that was it though
that's they just you know they're trying
to make it clear you cannot question the
results of the elections period don't
tell that uh kill chain uh documentary
on hbo that's the exact same thing by
the way
in georgia with stacey abrams in that
last election where they hacked the
dominion voting machines just to be
cleared blockchain on hbo you can go and
watch it i love you on star trek
when stacey abrams actually said that
the election was stolen from her by the
current governor kemp i believe
georgia that's right she still has yet
to concede still has yet to conceive it
still says it was stolen from her yeah
she's still allowed on every news
station and on youtube and on anything
else yes grossly overweight you say it
you're allowed to have an opinion yep
yeah
you're absolutely allowed to have that
opinion it can be wrong
by the way there's also a big difference
between being wrong and lying i want to
be very clear here yeah i am not saying
that the media was wrong or that garland
was wrong yeah they were lying we're
going to talk about it more with donald
trump jr who will be on a little bit but
right now many of you have been asking
of course you've said hey we thought you
were coming back with a new studio we
actually do have some
new updates here in the studio but uh
because of you know uh supply chain
issues right yeah we've had to build a
lot outside here you'll see in the
offices and a new studio so we actually
have uh on the ground in the office uh
finnegan to show you what we've been up
to here
[Music]
all right on the ground our
correspondent thomas finnegan can you
hear me sir
i see you and yes i can how are you i am
doing fine thanks can you tell us where
you are and what you're going to do for
us here today
you um
wanted to show you around
okay
hey camera guy get up a little bit
closer there unfinished space so
if you look here yeah show them all the
construction we've been working out
and i'll walk you through here so this
whole area from here on is brand new
okay nice little lounge here where you
could watch
the things you like to watch okay and
that people been using that but enjoying
it
not yet but if you continue down this
way we have a full gym oh a gym okay
that's right too we have a gym here
because a lot of them go all the
equipment you can think of anything you
could
possibly want or need yeah i think it's
missing a couple of medicine balls it is
missing a couple of medicine balls but
uh what have you what's your uh your
bench up to there finnegan
um
i'll give it a whirl later and i'll let
you know okay good that'll be coming
this way yeah follow me down this
hallway
we've just doubled our space for people
who don't know it's been a lot of work
yeah yeah
this will you know i i've sent you uh
some information on what i think could
could work here for this space
um i'm not sure if you had a chance to
join this is this is by the way the new
studio space because we'll be producing
other shows here that's right finnegan
you have sent me but they're all grossly
over budget
well i'm not in charge of the budget so
uh we could pare it down if necessary
well you know we'll have to exit
finnegan it's not even close
we will work something out okay continue
this is mainly storage but that's right
we've had to increase a lot stories we
really needed because
we just didn't have enough
and
we're going to have a lot of space oh
uh
you can't be back here
i'm sorry i'll be out of here like that
okay
[Music]
admonish by the way that was meth
that was not crack yeah i know meth when
i see it so does yakuza
yeah
well i love it we smell it here every
day because that guy keeps sneaking in
yes it is can you admonish
him for yeah yeah well admonish whoever
that was a construction
daddy likes to be admonished all right
and i will stop selling it to him yes
yes dave and uh well i don't hit the
share button by the way share the show
if you're watching right now sharing is
caring it is there you go hit the share
button it helps with the algorithms you
can like comment share sharing helps a
lot okay speaking of uh crack smoking
native americans i'm going to use the
term indian because that's what they
used then yeah to be clear so if you're
offended you're offended with the indian
when will then be now
soon
did you anything else you wanted to
touch on the fbi stuff are we good no i
think we're good for now there's some
other stuff that we're looking at
because every detail that comes out just
points in the wrong direction for this
stuff oh okay but we'll
are you looking at not ending your
phrases in a preposition no no no i
don't know how to do that okay what a
run on the sentence good old shakespeare
over here
is something up with which i shall not
put i guess it's a wine o'clock
somewhere yes
in his car this morning you've been
reading his pinterest too
or just his t-shirts yeah or his
etsy
hey by the way if there is someone out
there who's crafty who does etsy i could
probably what's the email people would
send general stuff to on the in the
website i'm not sure why i think tips
tips tips i need someone who can like
put together like some homemade uh
lotion for etsy that's a pizza
yeah yeah yeah you know i just need
someone to help with something it's a
project we're working on all right yeah
if someone does it you know
i know you're probably really busy with
your fledgling etsy empire homemade
lotion a basket of lotion it's not as
bad as it sounds yeah i would trust that
okay
i made it myself
handmade all handmade stuff this has the
texture of elmer i walked into that one
but no really someone who makes soap and
stuff like that i'll explain to you yeah
that's better yeah exactly
it's gonna be out of the local surgery
center
so i got it all over me it's literally a
bag of fat yeah yeah
no i we here i had no idea just went
buzzfeed boldly go to their trash can
that's true
all right so the academy
oscar's the academy of
whatever uh still around they just
apologized to sasheen littlefeather
ah her birth name
yes um this is trending everywhere okay
they had little feather berg but they
changed this
that's exactly sheenstein little
featherberg
places bison's blood above her teepee
uh
okay this is trending everywhere it's a
largely horse crap and let me explain to
you why and this is just a perfect
example of they they're out of they've
run out of people to cancel here today i
mean when you cancel a sitting president
and you you get rid of him on twitter
like we just talked about you have to go
back and say oh people from a long time
ago did things that were offensive and
then they've run out of
those poor examples and so now they're
just making stuff up
and they're misleading you so i want you
to know if i want you to comment did you
know about the
wounded knee
two the sequel wounded knee two the
sequel because that's what little
feathers caused du jour what was her
raison day
really yeah or does she pronounce it
so
don't i don't think that's it's not that
interesting i have no idea it's true
either way there's a head rolling down a
that was a different role so the academy
apologized to sasheen little feather 50
years after she was booed um for
refusing marlon brando's oscar that
phrase just made me throw up in my mouth
a little yeah
she showed up not to accept
to refuse marlon brando's why would she
refuse it well okay i'll explain to you
exactly what you in the context they're
trying to say this is all over social
media right now that john wayne tried to
assault her and here's the thing i was
reading this morning well that's bad if
you tried to assault her they even
reported in some legitimate outlets that
eight security guards were required to
keep the duke from physically attacking
her the only problem is i couldn't find
any evidence anywhere aside from her
saying
like a few years ago that john wayne
assaulted her is it because they thought
he was actually the duke yeah
just ignore the gay walk eight secure
he was not the most manly man no he
wasn't certainly not used for later in
life riddled with cancer yeah so um here
she is little feather
stupid little feather uh speaking on
brando's behalf
uh rejecting the award lamenting the
treatment of the term they used back
then american indians the problem is
it's largely a lie but here you go watch
what they're circulating
accepting the award for marlon brando
and the godfather
miss joshie littlefeather she is
gorgeous though oh yeah very regretfully
cannot accept why this very generous
award
[Music]
and the reasons for this being
are the treatment of american indians
today
by the film industry
boom excuse me she's getting booed
she's getting booed partially by the
audience a split it's a split reaction
yeah
you'll understand why on television in
movie reruns
and also with recent happenings at
wounded knee
i beg at this time that i have not
intruded upon this evening you have and
that we will
in the future
our hearts and our understandings will
meet with love wendy got a straight line
thank you on behalf of marlon brando
[Applause]
this is the best part
[Music]
i don't know if i should present this
award on behalf of all the cowboys shot
in all the john 4 questions over the
years
[Applause]
you know today when he's older it would
be way worse because he's lost and he's
like well i didn't know if i should
present after that
little indian [ __ ] came up and ruined
it
she's doing language right out of gran
torino you're like he's got to cut his
mic yeah
cut it
couldn't she have just how many drum
ladies can you fit in a teepee well
realistically marlon brando was just
trying to cause a problem because he
hated himself and hollywood yeah yeah
and this was in a scale yeah where he
just started eating and eating she was
probably at home and was like
ascendant indian
i don't care what she talks about just
so the whole point of this was to bring
attention to what's going on you can
still accept the award and bring
attention to what's going on i love your
speech it's a very generous award yes
that's like a very generous award that
i'm rejecting yes boom and she's like
and uh
uh i hope that i have not intruded
that's all you've done that is all
you've done you have no business being
there you weren't in any films and you
only came out there to chastise people
that is intruding yeah you had the
platform you would have had the same
kind of coverage and it would have most
likely been positive if you had just
said thank you for this award this is
great i hope one day and you could list
your grievances and you can refer to
wounded knee you're still fine yeah
marlon would like to thank you for
giving him a giant golden trophy for
jamming tissue into his mouth to make
jowls yes yes that's what this was for
that movie he's a once in a lifetime
talent
i have to go huff windex now now excuse
me the burger king is closing and i pay
the money to leave all of the exeter
burgers and throw them over my face
this is a true story what yes he would
pay burger king workers by his house to
take all the food that was left at the
end of the night go to his house throw
it over the fence and then you just see
marlon brandon run out and grab all the
burgers and by he he means
hollywood's finest now
little feather he's a dumpster diver in
his own front yard and he's like i was
watching it and i i again this is the
memory holding that takes place from
where i was like this is trending right
now they want you to be confused should
and the recent treatment as native
americans speak the recent treatment at
wounded knee i'm like well a second wait
was this was this filmed in 1894 was it
because i'm thinking wounded knee was
you know late eighteen hundred that was
eighteen nineteen ninety three ish was
it 1893 yes okay somewhere in the 1890s
you don't need a fact check man within
give or take five years no that's not
what she was referring to she was
referring to wounded neat and by the way
the original wounded knee you can go and
watch a segment that i did on that a
while ago it's not exactly what you
think that it is it was a wasn't
genocide it was a one-sided beating with
one side swinging in the hammer the
native americans weren't unarmed uh
there was a bunch of confusion that had
happened that had taken place a gun went
off from one of the native americans
which caused all this crossfire horrible
actions on all parts and yes on the
settlers parts on the new
world
actors parts whatever you want to call
them at this point we're talking about
this is after anyway so the original
wound indeed not exactly what you know
wounded knee too
is complete pardon me [ __ ]
so this is the story you need to know
this because now you have the academy
apologizing notice there was a split in
the cheers and booze yeah you didn't
even get booze if i remember correctly
when chris rock was slapped by will
smith you got shock
i don't think he got booze because they
weed it out of the audience you all have
to be lackies like bill maher's audience
right they have a crowd animator you
train you're like trained seals so this
was a wounded knee too for some context
context matters the event uh was in
response to the killing of a lakota man
a guy named wesley bad heart bull that's
a bad name
don't be ethnocentric i'm not i'm just
saying if you're going to have a cool
weird name just make it cool yeah well
ed hart bulls
actually you have a very good heart
wesley future pacemaker recipient wolf
wesley please stop putting cheese on
everything yes coyote how did she get
little feather that seems like a dig
wesley the bad cholesterol
i'd rather be known as gerald the big
feather yeah well mime steven was the
first martyr thanks mom and dad oh
that's true so wesley bad heartbeat
12-inch feathers what's it called
[Laughter]
they probably thought he had a bad heart
because they waved some smoke over him
and it you know blew east like oh he'll
die young okay thanks scientist so
wesley bedheart bull was uh killed by a
white man a guy named uh uh jill schmitz
darl schmitz daryl switch spells oddly
really weird so here's the thing there
were some conflicting reports that led
to the murder then i'll give you some
information that does not involve
conflicting reports so one source
claimed that schmitz intervened and
stabbed bad uh bad heart after pat hart
knocked another man unconscious with a
log chain
but bad heart's friends this is the the
he said chief said they claim that they
heard schmidt say he was going to kill
him in indian
okay
so at that point we don't know he says
self-defense they say he was just racist
and he killed an indian in front of a
bunch of other indians just for the sake
of it all right here's what we do know
that's irrefutable all references
available at crowder.com in the two
years before the incident bad heart bull
uh had been arrested sorry i'm thinking
of
sammy the bull oh yeah sammy the bad
heart sammy the bad hug ravano so before
the incident bad heart bull had been
arrested 19
times wow including one for the assault
of a police officer
so we have he said chief said and we're
going well okay but hold on a second
this guy has an incredible criminal
record now schmitz pled guilty to
manslaughter was released uh from jail
after one day that's what people got
really weird yes people got really mad
about there are some oddities here
understandable so the american indian
movement uh aim not the messenger but
that's what they were called back then
the american indian movement
i love how these these big organizations
like the naacp
aim they can't change it now no you know
you can do it with a sports team but you
can't do it when these people have
declared this to be the politically
correct name and the ambassador
for all people in that marginalized
group not only well you're not supposed
to say indian what do we do we already
bought the plaque
united what college fund just just just
put an end yeah yeah
let's just do away with this
what does naacp say we don't know about
that just you know give us some money
yeah please
so the american indian movement of
course descended on bring us back to
wounded knee wounded need two
you know two tp boogaloo
uh
this is what happened i'll reading you a
quote here the references you can go and
check them out after fortifying the
village taking 11 people hostage and
pillaging the small grocery store the
american indian movement aim and its
followers prepared for the worst now the
siege lasted 71 days yeah two indian men
were killed by snipers several more were
wounded uh it eventually was resolved
after the federal government agreed to
investigate maltreatment corruption do
you see a trend here though they they
besieged a city right they took over
their own place and aim actually was
made up mostly of young kind of people
who indians who did not live on the
reservation they lived in cities and so
they bust them in to do this does that
sound familiar to anybody right now
similar tactics to another group that we
saw taking over parts of places
in cities and i don't know busting
people in from the suburbs i don't
understand i don't know i don't know i
understand the implication i had a
friend who was a missionary who had to
go to native american reservations to
teach them how to fish i'm sorry what
yeah weird that was someone can probably
find it you can probably find uh there
in the control room we can bring it up
there on on mud club these these
organizations exist where they would
have to teach native american tribes how
to live off the land because they had no
clue it's right had an italian friend
named johnny loafers who would go there
and teach him to make moccasins johnny
missing pennies loafers right
never had a penny
so take a penny leave a penny loafer
benny's to rub
running shoes what a mundane detail this
stupid shoe so four years uh after the
siege aim took over alcatraz island
declaring independence from the united
states very similar to you know chas
chop yeah
four years before the siege and then in
1977 a member leonard peltier was
convicted of murdering two undercover
fbi agents cementing the infamy of aim
so if you see them in other words what
you always need to watch is we just
talked about this being live merrick
garland right yeah when it happened he
said or someone said on behalf of
merrick garland they had no idea about
this raid sorry warrant i just don't
want to be hit with misinformation this
is what they do it's constantly laying
down landmines right we reported that
live okay he didn't know yeah but i said
that doesn't pass a sniff test he kind
of would have had to know understanding
how the legal procedure would have to
play out the same thing i want you to
apply this critical thinking if you
watch this right the story will be oh
the academy had to apologize because uh
john wayne tried to assault her try and
find the footage try and find any
evidence outside of her claim decades
later and then ask yourself why are some
people billing her
that's that's how this starts as we see
here we go hold on a second she's saying
wounded knee the original wound didn't
he why would people boo her for that no
the reason she was being booed is for
the same reason that if someone went up
today and said and on behalf of black
lives matter whom we all support
appropriately some people would say boo
no why because it's a terrorist
organization because we know that
they've embezzled money because we know
that they've hurt police officers that
they've destroyed cities not everyone is
on board with you so if you watch it you
go why are they booing and why is clint
eastwood so comfortable coming up making
fun of her because she was making
ridiculous claims and now retroactively
the left wants you to believe that it
was all true it's not at the very least
you have to admit that there are two
sides to that issue comment below did
you know any of this about wounded knee
2 lost in new york
was definitely worse
no so this comes on the heels my parents
are in alcatraz and i'm at wounded knee
exactly right parents are an alcoholic
sorry go ahead this this comes on the
heels of that right so they took over
alcatraz it became an international
story there was only one care kind of or
keeper of the grounds essentially that
was kind of chased away so it wasn't
exactly like they you know went in with
assault rifles or anything right and
they basically just took this over and
so of course all of hollywood knew about
this because jane fonda actually went
and toured alcatraz with them to hear
their grievances to understand what they
were trying to get and they were pissed
off about this because they're like
nobody else would be allowed to do this
if anybody else took over alcatraz you
would send in the cops and they would be
bussed out unceremoniously to the boats
pushed back over to san francisco in
this case they let them stay there for a
long time this seat had been going on
for a little while too by the time this
happened yeah it went on for 71 days
like we said how do you let something
like that go on for 71 days
it's ridiculous people get tired of it
because you're like look why aren't they
bringing a negotiator well
they tried to and they didn't they
spacey they had
was that was sam jackson and kevin
spacey yeah yeah yeah samuel don't you
dare say sorry that's true i'm not so
sad i don't know him that way you want
an eight-year-old
so i get that they were pissed off about
this like it makes sense because this
group was basically
trying to be an anarchist group to get
their point across and it wasn't the
native americans that were mostly making
up this group it was people that lived
off the reservation had for a long time
and weren't really a part of that
movement anymore exactly like what we
saw with black lives matter yeah just
busting people in exactly like we saw
with the ferguson protests bussing
people in from other places yeah i feel
like if that was brought up at today's
oscars though the only one that would be
booing would be like clint eastwood and
mel gibson yeah mel gibson would be
hurling anti-semitic professors
show us your church
actually mel would just be booing from
outside there's no chance he's getting
it exactly that little teepee lady was
making eyes at me you know it
[Laughter]
but i will give you one more chance
you agreed in the hot tub
oh my gosh we will take ayahuasca and
you will blow me
because i deserve it
that's the best part of those mel gibson
tapes is he justifies that he feels he
needs to because i deserve it like
you know what you already kind of you
already crossed that line when you said
that yeah she was to get into the hot
tub and service you but he's like ah
this is getting away from me i'll bring
it back
because i deserve it
oh well when you put it that way yeah
exactly i mean it's because he's right
so this is the justice department right
now oh on cnn that they would serve as a
road map
like of course in a manner that is
highly likely to compromise future
investigative steps oh what do you say
hey what happened to garland's 11d chess
ah we have nothing to hide and then don
said great here you go release the
warrant release the reason for the
warrant unbelievable where's garland is
it gonna give another press conference
i'd highly doubt it if anybody uses
whatever d chess in a reference in
politics can it just be a law they're no
longer allowed in politics yeah well i
love it john stewart said it where this
is bobby fischer is he dead or is he
alive i think he's still alive are you
good i hope he is samantha nationalists
the guy in the park who i played said it
was him yeah no bobby fischer's white oh
no this is what jon stewart said he's
like i can't i can't tell if obama's
playing 4d chess or if it's kicking his
ass yeah
are we just not seeing the moves yet or
is he just getting beaten up yeah so
that i think that's why brian's more of
a candyland guy yeah he really is 13
dead end drive shoots and ladders oh
yeah and much like mario kart his nieces
and nephews destroy him yes
um do we do we know do we have donald
trump jr is he is he confirmed
he's confirmed he's going to be coming
around a little bit later
they're working on that all right uh
let's uh oh they're talking about
giuliana here in cnn you know what we
usually don't do this we usually do this
exclusively on uh on mug club but since
we have a little bit of time here we're
waiting on donald trump when we take
some chats and by the way you guys hit
the like button smash that like button
right now if you're watching uh on
youtube and if you're not a member of
mud club i would encourage you again
livewithcrowder.com club you know
sitting president's son here on the show
uh you notice that we don't do nearly as
many ads as other shows we are entirely
funded by viewers like you and if you
don't want to join that's fine you don't
want the additional hour of show that's
i understand just i've made peace with
the fact that if people don't join along
the show will go away that's the only
thing that keeps the show going and
thank god we have enough people who do
support it yeah a little bit of march
sales too you want to support there's
there's a lot of different go to
crowdershop.com you're going to buy
shirts anyway you might as well buy
something they got this good message
this dad fights like hell that's a good
one yeah that's a fun one not so bad we
don't sell the area 51. this is a brand
new one that we did that's right you
said it on aaron so we just were like
well we'll throw that on a shirt yeah
we'll throw it on a shirt oh boy guys
best shirt they have i'm just saying
the problem is for a while because we
had a shortage of the specific kind of
it they didn't fit well now we we got
them back to the right to manufacture
yeah well there you go remember i had it
and it looked like i was wearing like it
looked like the bay based kid's shirt um
was it i don't know i just have it in my
mind because of that pubic hair cartoon
i was gonna say i don't that did look
like a baby attention i really did it
um
there's some more right there we'll
clean it up baby's kids don't let it
grow in the first place yeah well no
look
[Applause]
[Laughter]
just
don't leave it wherever it falls well
yeah you got what i'm not
animals use the corner i'm not going
through the whole thing it's just
just i don't know you know what i think
we should watch that again i know we
have to kill some time do we want to
watch the uh venus thing again we can
let's analyze this i don't know that i
want it it's a great lead-in for donald
trump i mean i get it it's for women i
don't i would never want i can't go full
bear we can either do that or make fun
of cnn they're covering more of a bull
market thing right i feel safer shaving
a porcupine
it's a more of a bad heart bull market
guys
were we saying there's someone on cnn
they're they're paying for what's
talking about let's see they're talking
right now and seeing about the justice
department uh opposing unsealing
affidavit these are the people who said
garland wants to unseal the warrant
let's see what they're saying now uh
diatribe about attorney client privilege
doesn't hunt at all everything he did
was not between him and trump he went
and three times told complete fibs to
the georgia legislature that's the basis
oh they're talking about giuliani
they're pivoting
well no in other words they want to talk
about giuliani because that's not a loss
that they've you know encouraged so it's
a target of ga election probe criminal
probe yes yeah yeah yeah yeah because
they said he didn't trust the election
yeah no no i got that i was wondering
what they were if they were in the
legislature a couple of times and he's
like that that that's that's what he's
going to get and maybe he made wrong
statements he's a thing there was a lot
happening with the election now you guys
have asked me i don't i don't believe
that you know the ghost of shabbos came
back and rigged the dominion voting
machines but look we know beyond any
shadow of a doubt that the pennsylvania
constitution was violated when they
changed the election 100 we know beyond
any shadow of a doubt that there would
be no way of confirming votes coming
from legal citizens or illegal migrants
in certain states we know that we know
that there would be no way of verifying
things like
ballot harvesting or absentee vote we
know that there's a reason that other
countries and by the way jimmy carter
amy klobuchar elizabeth warren talked
about election integrity go watch
i think it's kill chain on hbo kill
chain on hbo that exact he hacks the
dominion voting machine in georgia yeah
now i'm not saying that dominion was a
machine that had spyware from china what
i'm saying is they could be easily
hacked where votes were switched he did
it he drove by a voting voting location
changed the votes
and showed how it could be done yeah to
say that stacy abrams was robbed in that
election then all of a sudden when the
next election came around he said uh no
they've taken all the precautions to fix
that it changed all the machines no
and i think it only took a hand like a
few hours had a little bit of a hack
convention where yes they had the
machines in a room and they said all
right guys figure out how to do this and
it did not take long at all for them to
figure out how to do it and what he did
was it was simple he inserted a card and
basically every vote you did he based on
his programming it changed your vote so
you would push
donald trump for president potentially
right in this hyper hypothetical
scenario yes and it would change it to
another candidate so you wouldn't see
that yeah there would be no verification
and to be clear we're not set we're not
saying at all that's what happened in
this election i just gave you the
verifiables that did happen in this
election i'm saying that this was a
cause of the left for a long time
especially after george w bush and al
gore you can go and watch it and see how
they were trying to lead into the
election
and then see that they're basically
going to criminally probe giuliani for
confirming that or for stating those
same questions maybe some of the
statements were incorrect but this is a
criminal pro this is designed to
intimidate all of you and all of us by
the way into not speaking let's let's
get rid of the idea of the truth and
lies like garland like the fbi right
those are truths and lies when we're
dealing with elections let's just say
differing opinions different critical
viewpoints
it's not about giuliani it's not about
donald trump it's not about the trump
family it's about you
they have a very very long list the fbi
and the rs2 and they've got 80 000 new
employees hey we need to talk about that
more i believe we have them it's time to
get to the don jr
[Music]
all right donald trump jr can you uh
hear me and see me sir
i can i can how's it going steve uh well
it's been a week and by the way you guys
can download i want to make sure you
have this correct the mxm mxm news app
right donald uh yes okay yes uh trying
to bypass the mainstream media so you
can actually read what's going on and
you don't have to just trust what the
fbi has selectively leaked to their uh
deep state stooges in the msm i love it
this is one of those situations where um
we've been following this we were just
talking about this this week where we
were on air on thursday and the reports
were garland didn't know that this was
taking place and i said i said that
doesn't make any sense then he claimed
that he did know and then of course he
claimed that uh he was going to release
the warrant i know that your dad said
release the affidavit
tell people what this has been like for
you and your family first off kind of on
a personal level then i have some
questions for you but has this just been
absolutely insane
well it is the problem honestly stephen
i'm so desensitized to it at this point
you know what i mean like i'm so used to
this not you know it's basically russia
russia russia version
you know 29.0
uh you know they're going to get them
this time you know merrick garland he's
going to be incredibly transparent well
we're not actually going to do that
we'll say that at the press conference
but when my father says okay release the
affidavit yeah just like you know back
during the wikileaks hoax i said fine
here's my emails
you know then they changed their tune
right they they leak it to their select
people to try to this you saw yesterday
with the passports right no they didn't
take the passports in this incredibly
broad search warrant nora o'donnell from
you know big mainstream media no of
course they didn't they're there well
you know they actually did you know the
difference between a conspiracy theory
and the truth i was saying was about six
months uh it beca went to about six
hours now it's about six seconds because
it took us about six seconds to show the
email that i'm sure she didn't bother to
even ask if there was any truth to it
she heard what she wanted to hear yeah
she could weaponize that against donald
trump she puts up the tweet rather than
to take down the tweet she leaves that
one up because it goes viral and they
say well you know there's maybe some
timing here in another tweet that no one
had ever actually reached and by the way
who's she for people what's going on
merrick garland says he wants total
transparency we say okay they say well
we can't we can't actually have total
transparency because that would give up
our sources and uses you know they
needed the fbi's hrt
the hostage rescue team stephen like the
seal teams of the fbi uh to serve this
warrant from donald trump when they have
literally in writing like hey we're
ready to cooperate what do you need from
us he actually met with them he
discussed this with them it's an
intimidation tactic it's like the
gestapo at this point uh what's going on
with these people is truly sick
and it's happening in america the good
thing is that like they can't hide from
it anymore like it it's so over the top
it's so insane
um that real americans that have been
agnostic to politics they're watching
and they're saying oh my god like this
is actually going you know if this was
going on in a banana republic you know
the warmongers in big government would
have been overthrowing these governments
by now but it's happening now it's
happening with our fbi and it's it's
getting harder and harder to defend
that's the problem
yeah even on your show i've always said
you know we make the distinction between
the bureaucrats at the fbi you know the
lawyers uh that are functioning as part
of the deep state and the door kickers
but like honestly like
if if no one steps up and speaks out now
we heard there's some whistleblowers
maybe working with jim jordan i'm sure
they'll try to route them out but if no
one finally says something like and says
enough is enough like it's gonna get
harder and harder to defend this you
know they can entrap uh you know a bunch
of meth heads in michigan and pretend
there was an assassination plot of
gretchen whitmer to try to pretend
they're actually doing something but
every
shooter in america by the way did you
know their radar and they seem to slip
through the cracks magically because you
know they were some sort of they checked
the box that they're you know a minority
status and therefore they can't be
investigated by the fbi
downtown let me get into here real quick
two things did you know that actually
one of those fbi agents was uh here was
actually in communication with us here
for a long time in that governor whitmer
sting and uh actually was someone who
reported antifa violence to in utah when
they actually had a sawed-off shotgun
for ben shapiro one of them was arrested
by local authorities this guy jason
chambers took all the info on antifa
nothing ever happened and he was in
communication with us for a while it's
never going to happen that you know they
they want to get on tv you saw merrick
garland and you saw chris ray there's
not a two-tiered system of justice i'm
like really like they're confiscating
donald trump's passports picture books
they're raiding his home with the hrt
antifa unchecked hillary can take
literally hammers to phones that are
under subpoena and it's like you know
there's like there's there could be the
perception of impropriety here but like
we're not gonna look into that because
it's problematic you have hunter biden
in the countless schemes i mean he's on
video talking about you know the russian
mob may have one of his laptops because
all of our enemies have one of his
laptops at this point and you know
nothing to see here folks also his
friends by the way he just hands out
laptops like party favors let me ask you
this do you know why they took
a laptop with incriminating information
you get a laptop with incriminating
information that could be weaponized
against america like
i want to go back to hunter biden i want
to go back to it later but really
quickly did they tell you or does your
does your family know why they took his
passports did they try and claim that
that you know president trump you're
dead was a flight risk because that
would seem to be that i think they just
had they did whatever they want it
wasn't part of the warrant but they got
this warrant you know they say you know
it was very specific it was the most
broad thing ever because they're not
actually looking for anything stephen
they're looking to find
something it's not like they had you
know he has the nuclear codes and you
know they honestly maybe we'd be better
off if donald trump still had the
nuclear codes in the nuclear football
because at least our enemies would
actually fear us rather than looking at
the dolt that we have sitting in the
white house that's only encouraging our
enemies to act up uh it's
it's truly sickening did they go through
because there were some reports and
again you don't necessarily have to keep
in mind i'm just asking questions to try
and get to what the audience wants did
they go through melania's personal
belongings
i you know i don't i don't know i wasn't
there i haven't been involved that way i
just you know i see what's going on i
see the broad overreach i see it's the
you know 29th iteration of you know
russia or russia russia they see donald
trump as a threat not to democracy but
to their power as the deep state because
he's the one guy on the republican side
that has the balls to probably actually
push back uh and do something about it
so god forbid that happens they would
rather have you know a soft republican
than there that will let the democrats
effectively rule even if there was a
republican in power right that will let
the state keep doing what they're doing
make sure that we can keep getting into
war so that they can get their board
seats uh you know by selling countless
missiles and sending 60 billion to
ukraine that you know we can't ask where
it's going like we can't ask for
accountability i mean that makes you you
know you're a russian sympathist yeah if
you want your 60 billion in taxpayer
dollars are going uh it's gone too fast
uh and maybe we needed that just to wake
the people is that beyond saving let me
ask you this these in because i said
this on air when people were trying to
say that i was calling for violence no
when i said war what i and i said this
is a war an ideological war against
republicans i said any republican by two
o'clock today i think i said this on
tuesday who does not call or make a part
of their platform to disband the fbi to
defund or at least neuter figuratively
the irs uh
i will actively oppose uh do you think
well first off do you see other
republicans doing that and do you think
that there's these institutions i do are
beyond saving like you said it's gone
too far i think the institutions are
beyond saving at this point the only way
to do it is to you know just disband
them and and start over you know and
again like i said i've made this
decision i'm sure i've said it on your
show i always made the distinction
especially with the fbi just because you
know they've been in so many of these
shady things they've done so many just
lies and playing you know documents and
the fisa stuff for years you know you
saw the entrapment again in michigan
like
you know
i wanted to and i always have made the
distinction between the door kickers the
guys that have come up to me countless
times sure and just said hey like what's
going on is a disgrace it's a tarnish on
our badge we're upset but like if those
you know whistleblowers that seem to be
so protected and lauded they're turned
into deities by the left when it's
against conservatives you know if more
people don't speak up given what they
all know and frankly what we all know
you know that it's getting harder and
harder to defend that and you know the
left will say oh my god you
you're against law enforcement meanwhile
the left has been anti-law enforcement
except for you know they're
the only people they want to carry guns
are 87 000 new irs agents everyone else
in law enforcement should not have those
yeah um well it's they don't like local
law enforcement they don't like states
rights they don't like municipal rights
they believe only in centralized
militarized law enforcement it's
entirely consistent with their with
their platform hey uh i know we're going
to go to mugler beer not too long where
we can say whatever we want but let me
ask you this obviously you know you guys
are in florida and you guys were
friendly uh and uh camping with desantis
and now people are talking about this
election there may be you know in the
primary are you all regardless i don't
i'm not asking as far as uh
who's running are you all still friendly
yeah listen hey i don't know i don't
know anyone who probably did more
uh you know in terms of events and stuff
like that to help get him elected to you
know to beat uh you know his uh you know
met head counterpart uh you know in in
the last gubernatorial election down
here then probably me uh you know i know
it was very close yeah i know that
donald trump probably got him over the
line and i think that
that saved florida you know again i
think you see what what i see right now
uh is and i i think you'd probably
recognize that i'm probably one of the
you know conservatives or republicans
out there that's more on the ground in
sort of real america probably than
anyone yeah uh you know the base is
probably actually stronger than ever
last this week uh you know clearly put
that to you know a whole new you know
level let's call it nuclear manga yeah
as uh
as they've tried to do you know where i
see the pushback sort of that that donor
class yeah they don't want a trump
because they want to pick up the phone
get the president on and when they say
jump the president says how high yeah
that's the distinction that i don't
think anyone's talking about you know
they sort of uh you know the the
republican uh
you know cabal and the donor class you
know they want someone that answers to
them they want someone that needs them
and their dollars and stuff like that so
you know that's the only
uh and are you saying that desantis may
tread that he may kind of tow that line
a little bit well i i think you know
it's different when you're an
independently wealthy billionaire and
you don't need those sort of dollars and
you have that sort of you you're just
not as beholden to those people and so
i'm not you know saying anything about
him i'm just saying you know that that's
really if there's any schism whatsoever
you know maybe it's that because they
want that control again i think donald
trump's the only guy again that will
have the guts to just you know go you
know full scorched earth against uh
these corrupted institutions yeah uh you
know to try to you know again to drain
the swamp you saw what he did last time
and it was with unprecedented hatred
from the media unprecedented attacks
from the left and candidly stephen
almost no help from the right and i
think that tells you everything uh that
you need to know uh do you think if you
could go back do you think you would
have said oh uh maybe we not have
someone like array or maybe someone like
a bar because there's only i know
there's only so much you can do to drain
the swamp but a lot of these people
unfortunately you know if you look at
some of their vested interests it wasn't
necessarily um the security of america
or ensuring actual transparency
yeah listen i i think now we probably
have a much better understanding of you
know how things work than when we went
in there totally new to politics didn't
under you know you trust people to give
you advice to something like this and
say yeah ray has hired you know there
was probably a long list of other people
that would exactly function this way so
you know i think that's the point you
got to sort of start over uh you know
bring in people totally not part of that
system uh to try to salvage uh these
institutions or to just break them down
entirely and start over because you know
again i i don't think there's anyone
even even on the left they may not say
it out loud but they're looking at
what's going on and saying jesus christ
like you know again if this was going on
in a banana republic uh we we'd be in
there overthrowing those governments and
installing our own yeah hell even an old
navy let me ask what's happening here
okay so we're gonna go to mug club and i
want to actually talk with you about
hunter biden you know because there's
some parallels there uh obviously you
don't uh smoke crack and sex your niece
and you know give away secrets but i
mean you know sons of sitting uh
presidents sitting former vice
presidents uh i want people out there to
know uh before we go to my club you can
download the mxm news app this is
something that donald trump jr is
working with and you know what it's
important because the first step they
took before they raid your house the
first step they take is what silencing
your voice removing donald trump from
twitter removing him from social media
and then of course they at that point
they can paint the picture that they
want you to see so the mxm news app
we're gonna go to mug club and talk
about uh hunter biden some new quotes
from him here with donald trump jr piss
off youtube
[Music]